how much of your budget was put on
credit cards in which you advised that
to other filmmakers I would definitely
advise another film a gift for other
funders to do if they believe in
themselves their team and the project if
you do not if you're not willing to
depending on what what length you're
you're going to hear you're you're going
to and how much that you're going to
accrue and again that also depends on
what your end goal is you you have to be
passionate about the project because
unless you know you have an out which
are out is hopefully the movie hopefully
the movie cells well it gains exposure
it needs and then we can pay everything
off because that's that's how that at
least school work for us but yeah I
would definitely recommend it but you
got you've got to be on your game you
got to do your homework and for us it
was the only option there is no there's
no one knocking on door saying here is
you know five hundred thousand dollars
or a million-dollar to do your script I
mean we wanted to shoot a very odd film
the way we wanted to shoot it and
unfortunately that unfortunately not
many people wanted to throw cash it the
project and let the first time right or
first-time director first time it's an
attire for for a feature man the ship so
we that's why we decided to do it on
credit cards but in terms of percentage
i mean it's it's the majority it's
almost all of it so thankfully we were
we raised you know whatever was thirteen
thirteen thousand fourteen thousand
dollars I don't know what it is after
they take Kickstarter takes its cut but
that definitely helped supplement some
of the cost but I mean that didn't put a
dab done the overall
the cost of the film so it's the
majority but for film like ours and I
don't know exactly what happens for
other people but the majority of costs
have come in post-production and the
distribution release phase the movie
shot for virtually nothing it's no I
mean the costs were in the
pre-production and or the Cosford in the
post production and distribution there
was no cost really and pre-production
and production as we hadn't we didn't
have anything and I had also previously
read that a lot of first-time filmmakers
make a mistake or I was reading this
when we first decided to shoot it they
dumped all the money into the production
itself and the pre-production and
production so then they have no credit
card balance left over they've no they
have no limit they've already reached it
so it's gone and then they rely on the
film getting into a film festival and
then it gets picked up for distribution
and Baba and all those things might
happen but that's not reality I mean a
lot of films majority of films do not
get into film festivals so what I
thought would be worth trying was to
shoot the film for virtually no money at
all and then do the best job that we
could with that with the resources that
we had and the time available and
luckily were surrounded with some very
talented people and a team that really
was on board to do anything that we
asked them to and to shoot that for no
money and no time at all and then have
all the credit card balance or almost
all of it ready for the final stages
after reading those I did I read a lot
like case studies from film independent
and think that those are excellent
resources for first-time filmmakers or
from setting that phone is off um so
well the film is beautifully shot and
that's all your equipment you're using
yeah yeah she
it was Australian 5d mark two with a
decent lens kit all vol series lenses
and yeah couple video fluid head and a
basic interview light kit we didn't have
a lot of lighting gear um I would have
liked to have had you know light panels
and stuff and party knows and we didn't
have any of that we had some tungsten
bulbs you know our courts actually but
see you Duncan yeah yeah but most of my
stuff that I'd have done the previous to
this has been you know corporate stuff
where it's either you know be role in a
factory or you know talking head of a
CEO you need small lighting out here
light you know the classic stuff or you
know whatever so head all the gear audio
gear we shot it with one shotgun mic on
a 13 foot boom pole recorded with the
zoom yeah it was I'm sure a lot of
people do it this way but I mean it was
definitely something for uh it was it
was a very wild experience for us
because we had we had virtual Wheaton we
couldn't pay anybody that's the only way
but it could have possibly worked yeah
and all of the like the community it's
like all with what we shot in 12
different locations and each location
allowed us to shoot differ for no cost
we had in pre-production I spent weeks
getting like thousands of dollars of
food donated that was also another way
where we saved a large chunk out that
was that was close for them yeah for
shooting big time but other than that I
mean we it was it was hilarious we
basically Joe's operating the camera I'm
instructing like what we need to do and
he's saying that's not going to happen
today because of the lighting natural
light or it's too windy organism we have
one boom mic and no assistance and then
the actors are just walking around
whatever extra gear we had it was just
it was it was like three to five people
that basically and I mean some days
to me in the actors and then Andy's and
actors because the director to so he'd
kind of jump in jump I jump back into
the scene and then like okay roll audio
okay my god thanks gonna all right I
back here okie ever it sounds good okay
yeah I mean I think people would
definitely be surprised if they knew how
some of these scenes were set up
you